good evening
Candace and I are really delighted and
right on it be presenting the award for
the best foreign film so honored that we
thought it would be a great idea to
complete our remarks in a foreign
language
you go first Jackie the program there's
a scout Televisa is it a name group of
trees than being on the paths and on the
model J if used to vampy Eve olive oil
on direct they don't read more the
program's about my dream those are more
turnt longer affected said technology
Boozer yep on sake he's on to veil away
and something about yoga parking on
winder desert the metal pan we yeah our
viewers to pool eight honest we go a new
bleep artists of the old Oceana but back
to business let's present the award
certainly
in order to do that we must bring out a
great friend of the Academy the
president of the Motion Picture
Association of America this year Jack
Valenti mr. Jack Valenti
I was backstage and I said the shoe sale
I found and they pointed me here
bonsoir Madame now that I've exhausted
all of my language skills let's get on
it okay
knock yourself out boom boom the
nominees for Best Foreign Language
picture are from Hungary Anderson the
tragedy of a clairvoyant whose gift is
exploited by the Nazis in Belgium the
music teacher about a stern
disciplinarian and the singers he enters
in a grueling competition
and from denmark kelly the conqueror a
saga the hard life endured by immigrants
in scandinavia
from India Salaam Bombay which
chronicles how a small boy becomes a
citizen of the streets and from Spain
women on the verge of a nervous
breakdown which demonstrates you'd
better be careful what kind of message
you leave on somebody's answering
machine and the Oscar goes to Denmark
for Pelle the Conqueror
oh it's so so exciting so I'm very
nervous and I made a film about very
poor immigrants coming to Denmark and
yeah I'm standing in my tuxedo on this
shiny thing thank you very much and
thank you to everybody who has been
involved in this picture thank you the
61st annual Academy Awards will return
with the award for supporting actor